o ato de pessoal daqui que falou dar que
sejam muito bem vindos
é mais um vídeo e eu gostar de que
cresça de 2 toneladas contra coisas
nojentas e não só ela tem que escolher
algumas coisas que eu achei sim mais
nojentas né primeiro lugar eu fosse uma
galera que uma espécie fly london uma
moeda eu nem sei o que isto irmã de
banho gento aí
isto é muito estranho é muito estranho
mesmo essa vai ser a nossa primeira
vítima e ainda tenho aqui outra
embalagem que não abre ainda ok eu vou
abrir esta aqui e como podem ver aqui
dentro ainda está embolado e eu não vou
tirar o flamengo fechar esmagar assim
com a caixa
vamos ver o que acontece já está a
começar a sua gata golo ainda assumir
vejam só como é que ficou e eu vou
voltar agora como a peça meu taco lado
por aí muito pouco mas não houve como
assim
a tampa a entrar por dentro aí vai
entrar em campo vai entrar na fase
seguinte o furto já pensa assim não há
produção
oi aqui né
eu não consegui ver o que o fumo votar
mais não já tá muito difícil suportar o
calor era pressão agora o irã de que
iremos fazer oque eu acho que é um cara
riscada tirar o espectador olha aí uma
peça de ferro meu school completamento
tá completamente colado já está próxima
coisa nojenta um ovo de silicone
borracha coisa estranha que eu nem sei o
que é que acha que conheciam assim ficar
assim é
vamos lá pessoal osma gado em 321 eu vou
te afastar um pouco
lei é lei é muito estranho e está
prestes tudo tá muito talento à época eu
vou tirar a opção 321 pai ficou igual o
que ficou igual o hugo já não é um ovo e
se com uma estranha que vamos tentar
mais uma vez ver o que acontece
assim não vai desistir e voltou ao
normal o que eu estou vendo tabuleiro
isso é pessoal
a nossa próxima vítima não é algo
nojento mas eu quero muito partir de uma
cápsula de vidro não estava com o carro
ainda sobreviveu o carro ainda está ali
mas foi muito pouco tempo no brasil
o próximo objeto isso tenho certeza que
não vai ganhar a imprensa tem que ter
uma bola com um dinossauro aqui dentro
ok já tá bem no centro e vão só vou
estar um pouquinho eu digo o que
aconteceu tenho certeza que vai excluir
321 pai
ae a história do livro foi escolhido
ai ai ai ele não só está bem apertada
lija ai ai de nós já morreu
vejam só o dinossauro faltar muita penal
e ver o dinossauro ela está ali pude
jogar como assim é normal num ponto
muito
8º da lei em votação mas aí eu digo é a
porta livre próxima vítima é que o
mister esqueletal do mês o grupo todo
assim e dá pra ficar tudo só para quem
só se eu apertar aqui a cabeça de seu
site um equilíbrio mas tem uma larva
dentro não se conseguem ver olha
produção tem de apanhar calado fazem 321
muita atenção 321 mãe outra vez a série
de discurso que existir num evento indo
até lá vamos tentar uma forma ainda mais
a cork pelo aeroporto a cabeça e tentar
apertar o filme xuxa isso mesmo o grande
nó mesmo apertado 321 vai estar aqui
aí eu acho que é isso
tipo um químico qualquer meu gindo e
depois do ovo
galinha lei a e ela estica kit com as
patas a cabeça meu filho tudo a ela já
está bem é porque vim aqui vamos apertar
ainda mais 32 11 vai tá ciro ficou já
não comporta mais a demanda por seu
talento ao encontrar encontra a lei só
vou tentar só apertar o ovo agora a
itália tentar aguentar não vai agüentar
90 sua pressão está no máximo eu vou
agora tentar fazer um corte com um x-ato
e ver o que acontece mas produção no oc
3 2 1
[Música]
acho que é a água
olha aí gema
então é isso pessoal vamos ficar por
aqui e espero fazer tenham gostado e já
sabem se quiserem ter mais coisas quanto
a nossa presença de todos os titulados
comentei nos comentários como esse
comentário que pode ser qualquer coisa
do tipo um objeto uma bola tem alguma
coisa de 2013 e já sabem pessoal aqui do
consulado vocês vão ter dois filhos
provavelmente não viram e em cima vocês
podem subscrever aqui no canal dos
tanques fran e é isso fique bem e até a
próxima